[Musik]
in der letzten folge flight girls yvonne
boris berger holt die im ambulanzjet
frühchen juli nach hause
die mutter ist erleichtert heimzukommen
[Musik]
pilot philips siemens steht kurz vor der
beförderung zum kapitän
noch ist er im regal jet mit einem
instruktor unterwegs am harder ob
internaten ist eine ältere frau vom
wanderweg gestürzt
das team von riga 10 hat die suche
aufgenommen die tochter der verunfallten
ist außer sich folgt in der regel
zentrale in zürich bewahrt
einsatzleiterin geht die crew kühlen
kopf die crew von reger 10 hat die
verunfallte frau entdeckt und tommy vom
wie lässt sich an einer 60 meter binder
ins unwegsame gelände zur patientin
absetzen
ja wirklich gut bin wie sinnlose krieg
daraus ist da super suppe dann heraus
untergrund ruhe und träger zell
verstanden
er verstand ich bin patient ich als
mieter vor wild hatte tochter vor der
patientin am telefon begleitet bis 30
der heli ist zwischengelandet
patrick maurer steht in kontakt mit dem
arzt am unfallort
jetzt geht es darum baut und patientin
sicher aus dem wald zu bringen
angeschwollen
winters der sogenannte downloads darf
auf keinen fall erste abreißen
[Musik]
ach so
wenig neues gebracht
hier
[Musik]
staufen
für rettungssanitäter
und pilot rickenbach ist die mission zu
ende
[Musik]
und auch die dicken schließt den fall
erleichtert ab und zu situationen wo man
nicht weiß wo übrig und wo man weiß ja
jetzt blöd zwischen und
sanierungsprojekte wundert sich schnell
wenn ich meine august bisschen noch mit
cs beschäftigt oder willst du wieder
losgehen twitter finden und mit dem
bringst ich sehr überrascht
sieben jahre erfahrung helfen geht die
kundin ruhe zu bewahren
es steht das sechs abflog die tochter
ist überwiegend sie ständig nicht
sterben nicht stärker motiviert es ist
kurz vor feierabend auf der heli basis
in wilderswil jeder winden rettung ist
für den arzt anspruchsvollen selbst für
einen routinier wie tommy von will der
selber junge ärzte an der winde aus
bildet mit marco bezirksliste
rettungssanitäter oder ein autopilot
pavoni kennen und weiß dass die rente
die macht und sowie karosserie länger
hat also im team sind das ist nur so
einen hamburger noch 10.000 machen wenn
wir das mit der patientin cdu bezirks
ist macht leitet ist hier die infusion
oder medikamente ganz einfach viel
rassiger und sogar noch länger und
entsprechend deutlich stressiger reisen
oder längs der patienten im spital
bringen
jetzt im frühsommer ist um halb sieben
arbeitsschluss die crew darf die basis
verlassen
im falle einer alarmierung allerdings
müsste sie in 30 minuten in der luft
sein
ein bis zweimal pro woche steigt pilot
rick maurer nach der arbeit aufs
laufband
rückgrat nicht verkauft
daher meistens setzen sie zur porta und
daten
auch marco ley trainiert regelmäßig
als ambitionierter triathlet kennt er
zwar keiner gewicht sorgen doch für ihn
ist es wichtig den rücken zu stärken
weil er als rettungssanitäter immer
wieder schwere lasten zu tragen hat
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
yahoo
amsterdam am frühen morgen
ein rega team mit jetpilot philippinen
ist auf dem weg ins ausbildungsprogramm
im simulator muss der angehende
flugkapitän tagelang schwierige angst
vor situationen üben den vierten
schleifen gibt es nicht umsonst
drei monate dauerte ganze beförderungs
prozess das sogenannte upgrade private
musikalisch destination montreal und was
unterwegs passierte nichts
weil das sehr spannend schildert expect
the unexpected die trainingseinheit
absolviert dann die sind heraus sie eine
spezielle flugplatz trainiert innsbruck
zum beispiel lugano also flugplatz war
sehr angetan sind wir durch navigieren
das triebwerk probleme zum beispiel
dementsprechend positiv gespannt
es ist der vierte tag in folge im
simulator zentrum
eine letzte trainings gelegenheit die
entscheidende prüfung steht kurz bevor
und kandidat philip simon hat sich alle
szenarien schon ausgemacht
ein absturz zum beispiel wären sicher
dankbar sagt design ich wiederhole
aber dann muss ich sitze es ist immer
das risiko dass man kritische grafik
situation
der virtuelle jet etappe und die
probleme lassen nicht lange auf sich
warten
y setzt einen notruf ab punkt für punkt
arbeitet er seine checkliste durch
der instruktor bewertet jedes detail
[Musik]
ohne sauerstoff geht nichts mehr
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die piloten leiten die notlandung und
landen den jet nach diesem schrecken
flug ruhig und sicher übung geglückt
[Applaus]
spital interlaken nach der wind in
richtung vom vortag ist romy von viel
unterwegs zur patientin die am harder
abgestürzt ist
er kennt die abteilungen bestens neben
seinem job bei der rega arbeitet von
will hier als leitender arzt steht
besser wurde um futter schmerzen sind
jetzt auch im renntaxi know how und habe
und die stadt kremmen
die starken an der küste musiker und
denn eine probiert mit der schule
stoppen
erster schuss konnte und wenn die kita
aber mein name so stieg sie die
patientin wird noch lange unter dem
unfall leiden
neben dem schädel hirn trauma macht hier
eine knieverletzung noch viele wochen zu
schaffen
flughafen zürich im rega center tritt
einsatzleiterin gt kuhn ihren dienst an
damit wir wissen überhaupt und wann
wirtschaft fertig ist mir aber praktisch
ohne job wieder muss er wieder anlaufen
auf der einen seite die einsatzzentrale
helikopter hier erzählt im notfall jede
minute
11.000 helikopter einsätze gibt es pro
jahr
auf der anderen seite die
einsatzzentrale chat hier werden die
repatriierungen auf tagelang minutiös
vorbereitet medizinisch und logistisch
die rega flugzeuge starten jedes jahr
mehr als 800 mal einer der drei rega
ambulanzjet steht zurzeit in marseille
die rega crew mit flight mercy boris
berger wartet auf eine patientin
was ich inzwischen abziehen das
ausstehende was meine jungs auf dem
flughafen herrscht wie ip erlauben alles
ist gesperrt
im jet betreut die wolfsberger den
ersten patienten des fluges die rega hat
den 80-jährigen chademo am vormittag in
sardinien abgeholt er ist in den ferien
gestürzt und hat den oberschenkel
gebrochen
kongo
jeremy ist frisch operiert
zwei wochen war schon im spital eine
harte zeit für ihn und seine frau
mir geht es schlecht
aber meiner frau noch schlechter
es gab dort keine öffentlichen
verkehrsmittel sie war blockiert in der
ferienwohnung und konnte nicht zu mir
ins spital kommen
jetzt ist die frohe heimzukommen
endlich nach 45 minuten kann die
ambulanz vorfahren
sie bringt harkema gerber käme die unter
schweren herzproblemen leidet und nun
die ferien abbrechen muss schauen sie
mich an geht es gut gehen wir
wenn immer möglich versucht die
repatriierungen zu kombinieren und zwei
patienten an bord zu nehmen
aus kostengründen
es haben sich schmerzen schläge ihnen
die blutdruck manschette an
machen wir packen das heißt für infos im
moment dass gerade punkten absolut
stabil
aber ich muss ihnen ein gerät zu messen
der sauerstoffversorgung anlegen haben
sie waren genug wissen sie eine
zusätzliche decke
liegt sie in der regel drücken könne sie
erfreut extrem vertrauter ist ja einfach
froh wenn es jetzt endlich heim heute
also dass sie sehr dankbar
gerber wurde dem flug erst spät
zugeteilt
[Musik]
er hat ja initial eindruck dass sie mit
konventionellen linienflüge hätte keine
gebraucht werde
wenn ich mir so destination maße
illegaler vorstellen
wer das aus medizinischer sicht kann
muss jetzt zeigen
also ich denke die indikation dass man
mit dem ambulanten
[Musik]
turner arbeitsplatz bremen sondern wenn
wir die flüge und die muss es geben
der flug führt zunächst nach ungarn wo
die patientin uns steigen wird
[Musik]
auf der basis wilderswil wird der
helikopter liebevolle romeo tango
genannt immer mehr auf hochglanz
gebracht
[Musik]
du musst nur zwei rega center zürich
bringt satz zentrale ribery satz mama's
house richtiges berg verkehrsunfall
antworten dürfen kollision und frakturen
und das ist passiert ersatzbank
ähnlich minuten dauert der flug ab
wilderswil bei interlaken nach mamas
haus dem unfallort
die landung ist maßarbeit
und zwar an zusammenhalt im inselspital
sie mit 20 minuten 20minuten.ch thorax
konfusion up to me now trauma wehmut
fraktur gc 15 affäre abc.de stabil und
das ganze nicht nach frontalkollision
dürftigen auto mit circa 50
stundenkilometer der verunfallte hatten
besitzer des beschädigten autos
herangerufen er will sich entschuldigen
[Musik]
gespräche trotz schweren verletzungen
ein häufiges ochsentour
landung in bern hier im inselspital auf
der maternité verschläft frühchen juli
dem tag nach seinem überraschenden
geburt in athen wurde es vor fünf tagen
im regal jet repatriiert eine große
belastung für die mutter heute hat sie
besuch von judith rede ist vom sozial-
und betreuungsdienst der regel
nicht nur die frühe verdammt
judith iris besucht im auftrag der rega
patienten und ihre familien die
allenfalls hilfe brauchen das erlebte zu
verarbeiten
großes bedürfnis ist irgendwie die
regale oder vielleicht täte not gesehen
hat und irgendwann wird das team von
riga 10 bringt den verunfallten pfarrer
inzwischen in die notfallaufnahme
ich wollte roth ist dass die schweizer
haben sich schwer verletzte patienten
kommen zur erstversorgung in den so
genannten schockraum
[Musik]
es geht um stabilisierung überwachung
und genaue diagnostik
[Musik]
auf dem weg durch das geht bei leipzig
bewusst
erst später steht fest der patient hatte
den oberschenkel mehrfach gebrochen
die fraktur war aber nicht offen dazu
kommen weitere brüche an warten und
schlüsselbein
jetpilot philipp sémon hat nach dem
simulator training frei ihr 15
autominuten vom flughafen zürich lebt er
mit seiner familie hier hat der freien
blick auf die landenden flugzeuge die
fliegerei ist siemens leben zwölf jahre
bei der rega haben ihn geprägt
es gibt unglaublich viel geschichte und
eine niederlage und ein entsprechendes
gerät wirklich genieße jeden tag seinem
hund das leben ist trotzdem dass eben
netz gemüse skv hüten oder studio das
mit fromme erklären die biene die hier
angreift gehört philipp sémon die
imkerei ist sein großes hobby
hartz iv liegt ja es gibt parallelen zum
flüge durch revolution eigenes menü sie
hat waren wir nervös sind und da gibt es
geräte was passiert noch langsam schiebt
sich ziehe und um die welt der rother
nervöse dem saal brysch der ist nervöser
werden das über 30 12 und das warten
damit der kritik möglichkeit
grundsätzlich zugestimmt
ob es mehr reagiert immer wieder anders
das ist ein mangel spitze
dann geht es wieder dicke backe backe
kuchen hand seit noch 700 bären stecken
wir die unterlagen 700 stiche hat sie
immer noch nicht beisammen
jetzt sucht der anti nur
ich muss mal sah
rostock der gewinne
irgendwer ist schlusslicht opfer
konstant mögen und damit oberhalb vom
magazin gestochen
da ist es doch wenig wenig stiller dass
das nicht zu verspielt
wegen der noch box das muss wirklich
nahe
letztlich gehe es richtig und den griff
die luft schmeckt die freude
die wissen genau wer ich bin dass sich
hier beteiligen wir uns doch weg link
vom trust und pennon sprachen daher an
zwar nicht das freut mich natürlich
entsprechend zu schüren
der rega ambulanzjet ist im anflug auf
lugano
freitoss yvonne hobbys berger sorgt für
die beiden patienten an bord
[Musik]
dollar
valascia
die piloten machen sich bereit für die
zwischenlandung das wetter zeigt sich
allerdings nicht von der besten seite
lassen sich die wolken berge fliegen
[Musik]
geschafft die sicht ist wieder frei
ein film der im simulator geübt wird
hefti
[Musik]
gerber ist in der heimat
nach hause kann sie allerdings nicht sie
braucht spitalpflege
sie können es behalten als souvenir
[Musik]
der rega jet fliegt nun weiter nach
zürich dort ist der einsatz am abend zu
ende
[Musik]
wer das viel zu frühe stunde
rettungssanitäter marco ley ist wie so
oft mit dem velo unterwegs
wie immer beginnt der tag mit einem
gemeinsamen frühstück und dem briefing
heute im einsatz arzt ivo breitenmoser
er ist einer von sieben anästhesisten
oder intensivmedizinern die regelmäßig
für rega zehn arbeiten zu 52 meter co.uk
ganz klar darum zum trotz ist daher
schon tendenz dass es oft um auf der
basis hat jeder mitarbeiter seine
endlich die marktmacht raum graz der
medizin rom und pilot garderobe und
lockt auch genannt wie genau hat man
doch gemacht und das ist klar mit real
aber hier tauschte und darum schätzt so
werde das ist schon super ist also ich
würde nicht nur sie zum glück nicht nach
mini werbefreu.de
das ist gut die aufwachsen vielleicht
einfach nicht meine berufung
[Musik]
ja das gibt die häufig früher und zwar
hat das geschick des vfb und zwar
optisch zwei flüssigkeiten buch nach
einem sturz die ich noch spielen die
männer etwas geworden
schon ist romeo tango hoch über dem
thunersee
[Musik]
für die
spielverlegungen machen mehr als ein
drittel aller rega heli einsätze aus der
transport von kindern aber ist nie
normalität
die kleine ahnung ist auf dem spielplatz
am klettergerüst bäuchlings auf eine
straße gestürzt
[Applaus]
die mutter wird dem helikopter
mitfliegen
bequem ist
möglicherweise ist das habe woche blöd
dem buch von der leber milz oder so und
darum geht's in das spital auf buy
belassen
[Applaus]
korrigiert wurden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das mit auf lustige weise die partie
[Musik]
tun haben
wieder steht das team von reger 10 im
schockraum des inselspitals
die grünen haben für den kaum kritik
nach
zu hause bei jet pilot philippinen polen
office statt cockpit
der wille ist richter gleich gemacht
das auge die stadtschule über gemacht
und vorne wurde sie zum arzt
kortison holen damit die schwelle
möglich schnell zurückkommt das heißt
wurden der vielleicht flüge wenn sich
zwei kranke tisch und die steuerrechts
comicszene
und jetzt mit dem kroatischen
ermöglichen als hugo soll das ist gut
machen und dann hoffentlich mit der
rückgewinnung widerruf kann wie lange
bleibt philipp sémon flugunfähig in den
nächsten tagen müsste er seinen prüfungs
flug antreten um zum captain befördert
zu werden
ebenfalls in der nächsten folge im
inselspital hat die kleine anouk besuch
von der ganzen familie und von der rega
flyers ebersberger genießt einen freien
tag zu hause bei ihren tieren
und rickmers nebenjob regelmäßig fliegt
der rega pilot kommerzielle einsätze als
fliegerisches training
[Musik]